Німеччина проти Саудівської Аравії.
Генеральна репетиція перед відправленням на світову першість.
30-тисячний стадіон у Леверкузені заповнений вщент.
Ми спробували знайти тих уболівальників,
хто збирається поїхати в Росію підтримати свою команду.
Я навіть не планував в цьому напрямку.
Я ще жодного разу не був на чемпіонаті світу.
Але в Росію я б з'їздив. Звичайно.
Це дуже обтяжливо. Моя любов до футболу вже не так велика.
Чому не їду до Росії? О, це далеко.
Мені потрібно працювати, у мене не буде відпустки.
Німеччина - країна запеклих футбольних
уболівальників, і нинішній ЧС - не виняток.
За кількістю куплених квитків німці - на 5 місці.
Однак знайти на стадіоні тих, хто поїде в Росію, нам не вдається.
Крім двох основних причин - дорого і далеко,
багатьом заважає мовний бар'єр.
А для деяких грає роль і політична складова.
Я не можу собі дозволити поїздку на ЧС.
А по-друге, не хочу їхати до Путіна.
Політика - не в моєму стилі.
Демократію в Росії я вважаю не дуже хорошою.
А країна красива, я б з'їздила. Але, на жаль, зараз не виходить.
Футбол. Це не політика, а футбол.
Як в Німеччині, так і в Росії повинні усвідомити,
що спорт і політика - це різні речі.
Якщо їх розумно розділяти, то вийде чудовий
чемпіонат світу. Для Росії і для всіх.
Вже у вівторок бундестім вирушить до Росії.
Головний тренер Льов застеріг гравців від скарг на навколишні умови.
Їх чекає цілий місяць - не тільки спортивних випробувань,
але і зіткнення з абсолютно іншою культурою.
Російські хулігани користуються не найкращою репутацією.
Але ви ж кремезний чоловік?
Так, але вони теж міцні.
Згідно з опитуваннями, у німецьких уболівальників
трохи знизився інтерес до великих фан-зон.
У ФРН більшість будуть дивитися чемпіонат перед телевізором вдома.